okay in the first video of the last
Gateway video this is part two I left my
other arm this hanging hanging down here
that's not my style you can watch all
the other
uh videos on it do you mean knock it on
the ADB nugget playlist but what I'm
showing you is that the kazushi is in
the hand on the neck
okay
it's not if you have to cut down go to
the inside grab the shoulders pull the
collar
you're not doing hiking you're doing an
external engine to generate a tilt in
his spine okay
so that comes into play on the second
idea adhesion
on this one
okay because I can't
you can't use the other hand okay but
what you tend to see is I'm gonna leave
him there
and then I pull him onto my shoulder and
you have another fulcrum lever engine
and again fulcrum lever engines work
but they're not guaranteed
so as he gets up and I start to pull him
and he resists
I'm not gonna get there you see and I go
like this and I start using two hats I'm
not gonna get there
what you're going to do instead is very
much like in the beginning of this
Gateway Aikido video his energy is
coming this way and then I can lead it
forward
so it is energy
is coming up
take it forward
[Music]
that accomplishes
the solving the problem of that inferior
fulcrum lever engine but I obey the rule
that UK should never stop moving
okay
so if you look at the other one even if
I was strong enough
it's me going around okay
do you think
it has stopped moving their Center has
stopped traversing the map but if I keep
the ivy going he gets up comes around
okay
the adhesion is exactly the same as this
one
it just go in here
okay
you don't need the other hand you don't
need to hook underneath his chin you
bring him forward
into that figure eight and eventually by
going forward he's going rearward
let's try
so if you pay attention
this time is also not necessary for the
threat
okay
the
reason for this is you have to pay Yin
in young Harmony so let's say I'm going
to cut down on this see well his energy
was going forward that's still a young
Clash okay but his energy is going
forward and I hook on it and I take it
on the curb it's still going forward
it's just on that curve that's now going
rearward
same thing if I come over here and I go
to do this
if he's not yet going backwards when
this arm touches him that is now a young
class because I'm lifting his knots
[Music]
so the Young art of the of the
identifying edema Nagin
is after he passed that young Apex and
is now starting the yin phase
this adhesion
got him to do that away boom and now I
can come in okay
if you're externally doing these things
pushing it down boom it's very difficult
to do this effortlessly but if I'm
working the adhesion it's very easy
I don't have to work anything
it's the same adhesion on his face I
don't know if you caught his skin moving
I use right here
[Music]
try without the yarn